what's up it's Lamar Odom check me out
on the bootleg Cav podcast 100.
bootleg cat podcast we got a legend in
here man no I'm not a legend bro you are
a legend no well look I grew up watching
you play basketball at a very high level
I'm 35.
so that was like my error you know what
I'm saying Lamar Odom is here man what's
good what's good bro it's crazy I just
uh
just so randomly like last week I was in
Phoenix at my parents house and I um
I pulled a lot of my old [ __ ] out of
storage and I found um the Slam Magazine
cover with you and uh Darius miles and
was it cute rich on it was that one
brand that's right yeah yeah
legendary cover yeah that was my idea
too for us to um weigh each other's
jerseys and put them on backwards yeah
they also don't cover them yeah that was
a it's crazy because like when you go
back and look at the roster of like
those some of those Clippers teams you
were on
just so talented man just like it just
did I guess it didn't work out but [ __ ]
you guys had you guys are deep if we had
if that team would have had like
one did we hit the mic in front of you
oh yeah
if that team would have had like um like
one veteran yeah that was like
respecting the league that we could have
like learned from because everybody was
young good habits yeah yeah it was just
out there hooping yeah it was crazy
how crazy was it back did you guys like
when you were playing for the Clippers
did you like know
much about Donald Sterling being like a
a [ __ ] or was it like you know I
mean I knew that he had the reputation
that he wasn't going
pay anybody
cheap yeah so
um
you know even though you're young and
you understand the business a little bit
at that point in time in your career I
kind of
knew that I wasn't probably going to be
that long because I knew that I was you
know good enough to be a a max pay
player right and he wasn't gonna he was
a cheap owner yeah yeah he knew the
system on how to
[Music]
um
you know not
win games and still come up on a plus
side as far as making money because it
was like all about the bottom line with
him yeah so wild when it's like why
would we spend money to win a
championship if I'm making money at the
end every year stay shitty and draft
players and he had no love for the game
or for the brothers obviously obviously
yeah I mean I'm a Suns fan and we've
been dealing with oil the cheapest uh
owner in basketball for the last well I
feel bad for the strongest fans because
they ain't gonna never get what probably
which I probably deserve
prior to change the mascot what does
that mean
you don't like the gorilla
no bro
do you think there's like some racial
connotations with the sun's gorilla come
on bro
and then the thing that's funny is like
they kind of like slick slid that one by
all these years nobody like
says anything about that well okay
it is random gorillas in the desert they
you can't find anything well that's what
I was gonna say you could probably find
a cactus
or in terms of like the animal chosen
we're in Phoenix it's the Suns I don't
know what they're saying basketball bro
it's just like come on
you think it was on purpose but you know
what's so really crazy about it
or is that it was a um
they just tried it
because they wanted to get some they
want to get the fans involved right
and
that's the reason why they kept it
because the fans loved it but you don't
think it was like Jerry Calandra was
like not purposely trying to I'm just
saying though yeah it's not good
representation because Phoenix is like
the last
City to recognize Dr King
man I already know
Phoenix has a gorilla okay we do have
some terrible histories it's just like
how they changed would they change the
Redskins and the Indians to the
commanders yeah I think it's probably
probably about that time as a woke young
black man in America right now in this
climate
I'm surprised Chris Paul hasn't said
anything about it
you know what it is man the sun's
gorilla is so popular in Phoenix yeah I
bet it is
I bet it is it's like and that guy and
and the uh mascot is one like mascot of
the year so much yeah and then there's a
wild crazy gorilla he ain't like tamed
or nothing like that
nah he's a pretty chill gorilla no well
if we're jumping up off the roof and all
that I mean he's a mascot I've been I'm
not I've been watching it though I'm hip
to it yeah you know what I mean and um
you know I have 42 I'm just I'm just
looking at toast that thing's totally
different I'm 43. I respect it you know
what I'm saying yeah and I'm just saying
like
any chance you uh was there any any
discussions where I ever thought you
might end up on the Suns no no
it was crazy because when I was playing
this that's something that's just just
went over my head
the gorilla yeah like I think I probably
started paying attention to it a little
bit more when I seen um
secretary Shabbat is doing the MCN yeah
sure that's his head yeah yeah he was
he's he said is a a great DJ too yeah he
is yeah does radio and [ __ ] he's a
legend in AZ for sure shout out to said
and a Lakers Legend he made all seasons
though did he make the list the top 75
list that's liquor
I'm not sure he's on that you you were
on that right yeah well first of all
congratulations thank you because that's
a big honor to be I mean the most
storied franchise I'd rather have my
number retired
you think that's coming I don't know
[ __ ] I mean
I don't know I mean I feel like I bet
you one thing I own [ __ ] get an
individual award
and shoot a reality show the same season
you know what I'm saying
because you can find myself on the back
but you got six fan of the year that
year yeah I shot I was shooting Chloe
and Lamar that year I forgot you guys
had Chloe on Lamar I definitely watch
that damn
yo just that whole like
era of the Lakers was so wild to me
because like I think like you got traded
for Miami
there was like a point in time where
like Kobe was a little unhappy
I forget it was I think it was the year
before you guys got Pau Gasol right yeah
I remember like Phoenix talk radio
everybody was like yo the sun's might
try to trade for Kobe and then it
obviously didn't happen but if
he probably was bluffing just to make
things happen overnight because that
Chris Paul trade like he wasn't going
ever girl we would have never left L.A
he wasn't right crazy what was it like
being on the team when the league shuts
down the Chris Paul trade well for me I
was happy because I was in a trade you
were supposed to get sent to New Orleans
yeah yeah what year what was that like
oh 708 I was
11 I think Pal Gasol was in the trade
route 10 or 010 or 11. you were in the
trade pow was in the trade
it doesn't happen David Stern shuts it
down you're happy though because you
want to stay in L.A
yeah
was that weird coming back to the team
after he like they just tried to trade
you or did you just kind of understand
it was business
nah [ __ ] I ain't never going to leave
early I've been in L.A since I was 18
years old
but I just mean in terms of like that
Chris Paul trade not happening but you
fat you obviously yeah I was happy as
[ __ ] I'm saying but you find out you're
a part of the trade it gets canceled
when you come back to the team it's over
with it's over with there's underneath
the bridge knows under the water now
yeah I'm just happy to be back at that
point in time yeah would you I mean
obviously um
you saw kind of like both extremes of
playing in LA from the Clippers
seeing how it was
even though you guys were in the same
building did you feel that like just the
different like
organizationally did you feel the
difference in terms of like management
culture all that [ __ ] well everything is
different yeah you know what I mean
expectancy the expectations are crazy
yeah like the Clippers
um
to this day
you know if they had a better season
than Lakers and you know then they had a
great season yeah and also no one gives
a filming the lake is trying to be the
best team in the NBA yeah so I think
that's the difference
in the town too
[Music]
there ain't no difference oh no no if
you live here you know nobody [ __ ] with
the Clippers no they do but not many
people they do yeah there's a there's a
few a couple shout out to my man clever
Darrow Clipper Daryl I mean I'm gonna be
I'm gonna keep it real with you he's
lost bets to me
you know shout out to my man Kadeem
Hardison
Malcolm in the Middle
like they were there when
we was expected to lose uh what's the
old old comedian dude's name uh
that's always at the Clipper games the
old white dude he had a sitcom
[ __ ]
you know what I'm talking about bro oh
no my rookie year bro we lost 20 games
in a row about 20.
so I mean who's average again blown out
you lost 20 in a row by 20. that's a
total fat is that a fat is that like a a
record I don't know probably got to be
close to it oh my God now was that the
year before was Michael I love candy
already with y'all yeah wow that was his
second year
yeah my rookie year was your second year
damn
great that's terrible
was Alvin Gentry the coach one of our
coaches oh man that's that's
like some Detroit Lions [ __ ] I mean the
Clippers Loke here like I feel like
before Chris Paul went to the Clippers
I looked at the Clippers as like the
worst organization in all sports until
they got Obama
right because the owner a team is going
to be a reflector of the owner I mean
even before he sold I mean when there
was Blake Griffin and CP it was like
okay cool they at least they're they're
good no yeah they were turning around
because the the product they had Talent
yeah yeah and there's some energy yeah
and Chris Paul was a veteran yeah even
though he had you know young Blake
Griffin that's what I'm saying that
if my team just had like a different
presence just a presence not even the
output on the court right you know what
I'm saying just to tame us off the court
help us with our practice habits and
[ __ ] like that that team would have been
made noise in the playoffs how crazy was
off the court
2 000 Clippers 2001 Clippers were y'all
hitting the club all the time all the
time I was like the kind of the leader
we used to go to the hotel we used to
get to the hotel you know meet me
downstairs
Studio
who was like your number one like uh
partner in crime it would be me Jeff
McGinnis
D mouse Q shot we was we used to always
hang tight off the court even the dudes
that didn't even really even like each
other I think I was kind of like the
bridge you kind of like bridged
everybody that kind of glue yeah damn
I can imagine Darius miles Lamar Odom I
mean we all in L.A
you know everybody got like a little
million dollars in their pocket mm-hmm
all into the same everybody's been to
the sneakers and girls and same [ __ ]
that we entered now yeah
um but it was new it was new to you back
then yeah yeah out straight out of high
school or college wherever he was at
yeah
Darius miles got drafted out of high
school right
damn so was he even 18.
or was he like he just turned 18 right
so you're just and that was 19 20 I was
21. you guys weren't even old enough to
drink we was everywhere and the clubs
are just doing Hotel parties Hotel
parties yeah crazy I don't know
so in the club in the club yeah I had
the NBA experience to party in your
hotel
we was out
I Can Only Imagine
that era had to be so much more fun
because you have so much less [ __ ] to
worry about the social media ownership
wasn't out so you could you could [ __ ]
off and like truly [ __ ] off and not
worry about being on tnz the next day or
Twitter or whatever the [ __ ] it is you
can have fun you can have innocent fun
and not have to worry about being on TMG
because you can like not do anything you
could just be out at a club and like I
just saw you I'm sure you saw they they
posted a video of LeBron gambling and
they're trying to make it like a bad
thing because he was playing Blackjack
I'm like who gives a [ __ ] exactly like
he's just you know what I'm saying yeah
like you got to watch your back
over everything now do you find because
you've been through so much man do you
find yourself
um
more calculated now in terms of just
like God I'm older I learned you know
what I mean you've been through like
I'll make the same mistakes of course
you feel me yeah that I made
um
when I was 19. that was that'd be insane
yeah
I mean I try to you know at least get
better every day you have to man you
feel me
um like look just think about it I got
suspended
twice for smoking weed so crazy it's
crazy probably cost me like 30 million
dollars if I think about it because of
the in it did it affected your next
deals because I was a free agent you had
a stigma oh this guy smokes sweet he's a
pro he's a troublemaker which by the way
now we know it doesn't [ __ ] matter
they don't even test for weed in the NBA
it's crazy so yeah you feel me yeah now
I'm about to get paid for selling we for
selling dope we call it dope I hate that
word it's amazing you got your own weed
coming out you feel me yeah what's the
week on
is Odum cannabis is with flight path
and on the first two strings it's going
to be uh cereal milk and gelato nice got
some dope package how would you guys
hide weed back in the day when you were
playing like would you know if you were
gonna get piss tested or was it random
yeah that's what I'm saying about the
youth [ __ ] right right like I know
that I'm getting tested
um
so you and you're still doing it
but you knew yeah
you were just kind of hoping that you
were like roulette with your with your
career
yeah like I know but you know I'm young
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah just like it
was the time where I like you know I
like to sniff Coke hmm
while playing no no summertime feel me
so let me get this straight so during
but during during your basketball years
yeah so during the summer off season you
would play with the coke perfect yeah no
I mean that at 40
3 mm-hmm
like I don't even really I don't even
really [ __ ] with no hard drugs now all
right you know what I'm saying
um
but why I'm 43. yeah got so much [ __ ]
out there you got this fentanyl [ __ ]
like that hot so that that 15 minutes
are hot is it worth well that's what my
pain is like you got to keep doing it
yeah it's like if you're you don't have
to but you're gonna want to no right
because like you said it it doesn't last
long so if you do it and you're out and
you're out you're having a night yeah
you're gonna keep doing it if it's
around what year how far into your
career did you start [ __ ] with Coke
my son passed away in
2006. so when you were in the Lakers
yeah yeah do you think that that was a
direct result of you dealing with the
pain from losing yourself it could have
been
I don't know I could have been it just
probably was I just chose that time to
party
you know what I mean made the wrong
decision actually opened up a demon
yeah but I mean you know
I regret having to learn about myself in
that way I'm regret that I you know that
I had that strong
um
herbs of addiction that way you feel me
you have such a hard I mean that's
something that you never get over either
man losing a kid yeah no that's the
opposite of um our life cycle right we
don't think that we're supposed to
bury our children our children supposed
to bury us exactly man that's that's
tough that's definitely tough man
um
have you ever because you know obviously
you've dealt with addiction
I know people who have done like
Ayahuasca retreats to try to like break
through well I did I did something
that's some similar to that because you
do I did um eyeball game what's that
um it's a plant medicine okay it's
supposed to be like the strongest
psychedelic yeah psychedelic medicine
and um I did a lot of drugs in my life
and that [ __ ] was
that [ __ ] was so strong I was I was
sitting there like and it was hitting me
I was like God please
have this [ __ ] stop was everything
visual
yeah I got to so you know plant medicine
is really spiritual of course yeah I
know people who say that they're
atheists and then they did DMT or they
did Ayahuasca and now they believe in
God because they're like so they say
that the first Vision that you're gonna
see is probably like the closest
person in your family and so hold on
open my eyes and I see my cousin Sierra
who I kind of like raised her and
[Music]
I kept hearing my mother
voice my grandmother's voice
the women in my family like my cousin I
kept hearing their voice and [ __ ] like
that
and I got to see my son again
I got to see him like the age where he
was you know he passed away
product age um
like 12 13 and then like the age he
would have been at that time
what that [ __ ] was trippy yeah
that was the only time he did it yeah
wow it made me want to do it again but
that [ __ ] was so strong I don't know if
I want to even face those demons Purge
myself yeah like what's the second time
like if you saw if that's what happened
the first time yeah hey we got to stop
the interview real quick you already
know man our partners in my bookie they
be holding me down when it comes to all
the money I'll be making on gambling on
these [ __ ] Sports man that's
right they're your sports betting Haven
all right and it is Thanksgiving week
big games coming up uh yo we got the uh
Cowboys obviously playing the Giants
Vikings versus the Patriots Bills vs
Lions I think the bills are going to
absolutely
destroy the Lions uh actually you know
you could put together a nice little
three-teen parlay on Thanksgiving so
while you're watching turkey you can
watch some football and you can win some
[ __ ] money all right but this is the
most important part when you go to my
bookie go to my bookie right now
mybookie.ag
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg
and guess what they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
so let's say Thanksgiving you're like
you know what I'm trying to get in on
some of this action that's cool sign up
in my bookie put in two three hundred
dollars they're gonna give you another
two or three hundred dollars of free
money to gamble with if you use the
promo code bootleg all right mybookie.ag
head over there right now sign up for an
account so much to gamble on right now
we got NFL we got NBA baseball's over
baseball's trash who gives a [ __ ] NFL
NBA and I think hockey's going on
college football's going on college
basketball is going on what are we
[ __ ] doing let's get this money
mybookie.ag go sign up use the promo
code bootleg right now and they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview you ever [ __ ] with shrooms
now you know what every time I I've done
shrooms they never really like well
because you're a big dude man so when
you they never like really hit me or
anything like that I think it's because
you just didn't eat enough because
you're you're a big guy we gotta put
them in like a milkshake or something
like that no no uh I mean you could eat
them I have them in gummies uh there's
chocolate they got gummies yeah
yeah they're fire
yeah
I mean you just got it I love candy as
you can see but shout out to the Nerds
um yeah nah you should [ __ ] with some I
feel like psychedelics like low-key for
people who deal with addiction or just
have like you know [ __ ] they need to
work out I feel like psychedelics is
like the way to go man yeah and it's not
addictive
it's a drug but like what is a drug it's
a drug according to the government yeah
whatever the [ __ ] that means like you
just said you used to get fined for
smoking weed as it cost you 30 million
[ __ ] dollars
nowadays everyone's smoking everybody's
smoke weed everybody it's like the end
thing to do 100 and they're even like
it's crazy too because now you have
active players
doing the weed [ __ ] like how you have
your strain oh is this it I mean that's
the um the packaging for it
oh that's fire the gelato the the
die-cut bag
cereal milk
yo this will pop dude it is gonna pop in
La too
yep see the bag's important that die cut
will stand out yeah
that's super fire
yeah good [ __ ] and you obviously you got
a quality test the weed right first
we shoot an American Gangster right of
course
I stand by you
I'll stamp it um
my product like Pepsi know what the name
is
hell yeah
and you have a Pepsi here
not a Coke guy
very few people in this world are Pepsi
over Coke my dad's a Pepsi guy yeah yeah
she's like a coke bottle yes it's like a
[ __ ] underground rapper
it's like man I was listening to
Griselda before everybody
[ __ ] shot the Benny's a butcher shout
out to Benny man
yeah what
um what are you listening to these days
we need a butcher love you some Betty
have you actually I know all this [ __ ]
let me shout out shout out to the
Griselda boys man Conway Benny locks of
course Jay Knox
King's disease three fire
super fire yeah
it's amazing it's actually probably the
best Nas album since
I don't know dude
it's a it's the best King's disease
I mean if him and hip wave put four
albums on two years it's the best I had
an illness moment what was your ill not
from Queens well I know you're from
Queens you're from Jamaica right yeah
South America so
I'm gonna lose that
I was out with
um
Taraji P Henson one night
we go to some little spot a date
yeah yeah nice
um
what'd you think I don't know
nice
um
I see nasty
I had to pull up I had to get a bottle
of champagne I got the opportunity to
chop it up when I see a jump
man to man one-on-one that's amazing
and that night
we was having dinner with
Angela Jolie Brad Pitt
dude
I got to see Prince played his crib
what the [ __ ] so in the same night
you're with Taraji P Henson on a date
you go to dinner with Angelina Jolie and
Brad Pitt
and you see right here and I'll see you
now shout out to go hey did you watch
ghost dog back in the day the force
Whittaker movie where he was the samurai
the Reza did the soundtrack it was
amazing shout out to him uh although he
was a what he was a samurai in in in in
New York and he was flying pigeons and
Wu-Tang did the soundtrack it was called
Ghost Dog fire uh Samurai yeah Forest
Whitaker he's like a black samurai he
like lives by the samurai code
super Fire movie with that being said
you saw Prince perform the same night in
his crib at his house
was Nas at his house no no I was at this
little Club
did you close the deal with Taraji P
Henson that night
who was like you guys were together I
didn't know you were with her
well look you got a uh
serious resume that uh Lamar Odom's got
in life I've been in La since I was 19.
man
what about like back in the day before
there's only fans before there's IG
chicks there was like the chicks who
would make it on like King Magazine
right like the glory of alez's uh what
was that one girl what's the
Rose now before her the Vita Guerra well
you know what those crazy about that
like
I think because of who uh because of who
I am where I live at
I have really access to
everybody right I was I wasn't that out
like looking for somebody yo when I see
him if I bump the tour or whatever and I
got the kick her to her yeah whatever
you know what I mean but I wasn't out
like yo if I see this one I wasn't out
yo let me send this one a message to my
manager [ __ ] like that I'll move like
that right but some guys do that right
they'll sound like they'll send their
guy to go have all the especially
nowadays you can't hit a girl up
directly you'll be on the IG and [ __ ]
like that right yeah they'll just
screenshot it every time I hit a girl
actually I'd be like let me watch my
verbiage you got to be careful let me
don't sound let me don't sound too
thirsty or too aggressive because
and get flip it definitely could get hey
tell me this you've played with some
great players
some amazing players
who is your starting five
teammates that you've played with
throughout your career and and on the
same team no no throughout your whole
career you had to assemble a starting
five
you're not on the team though
um
Durant
um
Iverson
Colby of course
LeBron power that's right wait wait I'm
talking about guys you played with oh
your teammates don't wanna play on the
Lakers with or play with that one time
throughout your career and you played
with that one time that was all on my
team one time LeBron USA
Durant USA okay take the USA [ __ ] out
Kobe well let's go through Miami Colby
Powell Dallas Kobe Powell
Kobe Powell
Dwyane Wade
yeah
um
Dirk Nowitzki [ __ ] yeah this is the
all-time great team Kobe
you kind of well you don't necessarily
need it pal
you had Jason Kidd on that map
Dwyane Wade
Dirk
I mean Vince Carter oh he had Vince on
the yeah
you put Vince over Jason Kidd
ing yeah I know I got time but not
overall right at that time
that's a hell of a tip you played that's
all to say though yeah and then you're
the Sixth Man however you want to take
it yeah
that's crazy that'd be a that'd be a
pretty wild uh
yo what how crazy take me to the 82
point game Kobe night you were there 81
or 81. why do I say 80s oh 82 is the
amount of games that get played
um the 81 point game though against the
Raptors where he was just I mean
legendary night man what was that
there's a reason why that coach
it's not coaching anymore who was the
coach
Sam Mitchell uh yeah
he's
the whole time I'm like
yo double team them I want to play
he ain't even changed the defense he
didn't change he didn't make no
adjustment hmm
no zone right we're just gonna sit there
and just let him just talk to your team
it's pretty crazy they had Jalen Rose
forever will be known as I mean an
amazing guy but also the guy who uh was
guarding Kobe most of that game
and we was down 25 that game
really
you know what's crazy about that game
like
I haven't seen Kobe like hit some like
incredible shots
[ __ ] that you can't imagine and just
that [ __ ] was just like basic Kobe
in that game just will yeah just will
just basic everything was like oh mostly
two foot wasn't no
one leg runners
[Music]
you know a couple of faded ways here and
there but
it was [ __ ] was just basic basketball if
you think about him
you always hear like um people say Kobe
could could be difficult to play with
because he held everyone extremely
accountable
yeah he's you know he's sick yeah he's
like a sick competitive guy yeah
he didn't um
it was hard for him
to
get along with guys that you know didn't
want these guys either
right you come from a losing culture you
spent a year in Miami decent team
obviously with a young D-Wade you get to
the Lakers just like Kobe have a chat
with you like hey shit's different no
but I knew Kobe before
before the um before we came into the
league kind of was um raised
um
and the same AAU environment so it came
through up in the Adidas circuit and
with Sunnyvale Carroll
but playing with them is going to be
different right because it's like yo
yeah but even through before that he
came to um I remember I played against
him in um that NBA camp
the NBA had their best their top 100
camp
and I remember
and this true story I remember he was he
came walking on we added at Princeton if
I remember
I can't remember he came walking on on
campus
remember we had no shades
this [ __ ] had on he had a
briefcase with him
what was in the brief I don't know
homework I don't know but I was just
like you know [ __ ] 17 years old
18 years old he got a briefcase with him
like he just looked real serious right
and um do you feel like playing with him
kind of helped make you kind of like
force you to kind of grow up a little
bit no it made me take my you know my CR
it made me yeah made me shoot for a
championship yeah you know so
practice at 10 you know what I mean hey
practice over at 12. I'm gonna leave
until three every day damn you feel me
so
man I could say he but see like he
understood that with me he didn't have
to say nothing right I got common sense
I'm like this [ __ ] is the best
[ __ ] league if this is what he
doing to stay sharp I think if I should
probably I could play
you know I got the talent enough to hang
out with him on my own but if I could
just follow and and take a little bit or
what he doing the habits the behavior
yeah maybe some of that star doesn't
fall off on me yeah because a lot of
people got the talent but it's the other
[ __ ] always the other [ __ ] the other
[ __ ] tally gonna take you so far but but
Tyler you could get off practice town
you could probably get away you know
three to 15 games we were getting
talented but if you wanna
40 50 60 games or the same [ __ ] being
consistent you're gonna have to work
yeah
yo let me ask you this as somebody who
has like you said earlier you know
obviously you struggle with addiction
when you see guys who are former players
um that are are in similar situations
um
I just saw uh
I'm trying to think what's the name of
the guy Delonte West is I mean you know
I know Mark Cuban tried to help him out
yeah
um he's still acting up yeah I don't
know what's going on with Ben Gordon but
he seems to not be doing the greatest
yeah but a lot of that [ __ ] is mental
health
Mental Health and using drugs is kind of
like oh they're all tied in
to the same thing really
I never really understood that until
like you know
until I'm at the age
that I am right now but I think what
[ __ ] is being truthful with yourself
about you know your situation mentally
yeah
you know what I mean and it takes like
how they say it takes a village to raise
a a child it takes you know
knowing who your friends are
because a lot of us have enablers around
us you know I'm special a lot of these
young black men making a million dollars
like that right yeah everybody just
wants a piece so they're gonna nobody
won't tell them no of course not even if
it's costing you your life because even
if you get high and you get away with it
that day or that night it's really close
to your life
you don't know it right what is the
craziest you're really getting low yeah
man look I think that that's
everyone if if you're supplying
livelihood for people they're gonna look
the other way if you're into some
[ __ ] because if you know how it is
if you're an addict the LA the last
thing you want to be told is the truth
yeah
you know what I'm saying that's the fact
what's the how crazy like drug use wise
what was like the craziest [ __ ] you've
tried
[ __ ] just I mean cocaine every which
form yeah you feel me
so you've smoked in this crack
basically yeah you you know what's the
difference because I'll be watching
[ __ ] snowfall the high is the
difference is it like that fire
what like smoking crack rock yeah cause
like man people will literally give up
everything to get more of it
it's got to be insane and and I don't
mean that in like a good way but the
high's got to be crazy
it's intense yeah
and for me I'm gonna be honest with you
like
every drug that I did was always tied
into sex too
um
so you would every Rich one yeah
Every Which one so when you were having
sex you obviously get the drugs involved
yeah always makes the sex better always
addicting to sex addicted to drugs what
the [ __ ] the same way yeah say hey man
Sexes I mean look man [ __ ] yeah feel me
yeah and nowadays
sex is more easy to get than drugs true
you feel me yeah hey we gotta stop the
interview man to tell you about our good
Folks at Blue chew baby that's right
make sure you go to bluetooth.com uh and
use the promo code bootleg yeah because
what happens at bluetooth.com is you get
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis but it's delivered right to
your door in a discreet package no
doctor's appointments involved fellas yo
it's getting cold as [ __ ] and you got
that dick you're trying to lay on a
lovely lady consensually of course all
right you might as well make sure you
show up to the party with all the
[ __ ] HGH uh you know uh
performance enhancing uh situations you
can have you really just need to pop a
single blue shoe and you're [ __ ] out
there man you're gonna have the hardest
[ __ ] you've ever had in your life all
right so listen go to Bluetooth
and uh use the promo code bootleg
because you get your first month for
free so go to bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg you get a whole month for free
try it out
okay try it out with that promo code
bootleg and don't forget they just
dropped their mint flavored chewable
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so that means it's
a little bit more pep in your step you
go to the mint you go to Old School
Bluetooth whatever it is you're gonna be
[ __ ] bud for sure you're gonna wake
up in the morning with the hardest [ __ ]
you've ever had in your life all right
I promise that's Cyrus he just takes him
and jerks off in his bedroom
he's got Bluetooth Fridays at his house
everyone's out there working Cyrus the
producer he eats a blue Chute he turns
the surround sound on he's got the
[ __ ] PornHub going and he's just
beating his dick like it stole something
anyway bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
and you get a free month of blue chew
right now going to sign up and [ __ ]
help us out because you know what I'm
saying we trying to get this money too
all right bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
was that what what was that um then you
know obviously you almost lost your life
it was very public and think about that
I did
and you know I'm admitting to you you
know doing drugs you know in the hood
that you would never do right
I ain't do drugs that night though
really growing up
so
what was what was it were you on Viagra
or some [ __ ] I mean yeah I was I was
going to have sex that night you know
what I'm saying so I Was preparing that
night because you had um Cardiac Arrest
right I had everything yeah I was under
I had
12 strokes and six heart attacks
and what so what what brought that on
the drugs that they slipped me I guess
oh they slipped you some [ __ ] yeah and
as a you know as a drug addict I was
like I wish you had told me what it was
because that had to be some good [ __ ] to
lay me down for three days right I woke
up I couldn't walk or talk or nothing
now I remember dude it was scary
yeah I think the scariest part for me
was not being able to talk
that's got to be frustrating you can't
communicate
you know that's got to be crazy
I was extremely humbling I'm just
thinking about I'm two-time NBA champion
Lamar Odom
feel me I'm laying and see the sign now
I can't even hold my bowels my G I got
nurses coming to change me every
three or four hours or something like
that
man do you feel like that it sometimes
because you know I grew up in a family
with a lot of drug addicts uh very close
to me and I almost feel like
you almost have to hit a certain Rock
Bottom before
you kind of get
woken up a bit or really truly evaluate
your [ __ ] do you feel like that that was
kind of like a uh but for me it was
confusing because I'm like damn I ain't
even do drugs that night
but I think for me that ultimately was
wound up being like the you know
it's those gas station dick pills man
the way that yeah
I think that I think that was the one
the [ __ ] that made me like yo you know
you could lose your life I got too much
to live for yeah you could lose your
life just living in a certain way man
well I got kids man my daughter's 24.
that's crazy
you got some grown-ass children man
it's wild bro you do man you do it's
been dope just to see kind of like the
Redemption story man I saw the story uh
when you were down bad obviously you
know you had to um auction your rings
off and the guy came up to you at the
Laker game
he just gave him back to you right
okay there's a fan that
all them dapped up right
I mean thousands of times
and um
you get a little closer to the bike
you see me at the first Lego game
right here like
Lamar got him
come on guy what what are you talking
about yeah
I was like I gotta get some shits
[ __ ] back where they belong I'm like
what are you talking about
it's like the [ __ ] Rings bro
I'm like oh [ __ ]
he's like I'm gonna you know give you a
a day will you come get them
I went back the next day they go
I ain't taking my French
that shit's amazing and the fact that
man act for nothing he didn't ask for
nothing because he paid good money for
the Rings like I mean they ended up
selling for like a serious
that's my man France yeah I'm gonna call
him French shout out to him shout out to
French solid [ __ ] guy solid dude for
sure for sure
um
yo obviously Kobe meant a lot to you
um his death is probably the most like
traumatic unexpected I didn't know Kobe
Bryant I'm a basketball fan though you
know and that [ __ ] really [ __ ] me up
um
for you man
you know
was Kobe always there for you even
through the low times because you you
obviously had a lot of a lot of love
yeah
always
should I take a shower welcome
moves on my being an addict you know I'm
saying yeah so
when I was playing
right
I never like gambled like heavy
like that
what else y'all doing I'm out the NBA
yeah
I'm not making
the money I used to make
foreign
pick up a gambling addiction the worst
how bad was it really about so
I'm gonna tell you why I got bad really
bad casual
that whole that [ __ ] that's a straight
line [ __ ]
because
she let you [ __ ] who's you thinking is
going to be all sweet yeah oh yes the
worst
listen you think it's gonna be like
that's all sweet all the time remember
the first time I would maybe get into a
heavy I was in I was in Florida at the
Hard Rock Me and My Man leaning free God
bless his dad
I started for like
no [ __ ] like 2500
I ran it all the way up to like 60k that
night and it was to me it was no better
feeling than going upstairs taking your
money putting it in the safe like gosh
damn
the same
demon like that cocaine Unleashed to me
man
so make a long story short
I'm in a hole like I can't get myself
out of it
I don't got the money to pay it hmm
you know what I mean
so I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
so
everybody know Kobe was like an extra
Frugal [ __ ] right
I'm like
I don't know I think I might have to
make the call this [ __ ] I'm like
I don't know if Mama
get cursed out
what the [ __ ] you doing LOL
called him
after he cursed me out what the [ __ ] you
doing hello so you'll just have your
people call my people
so he got you at your gambling hole
facts how deep were you in really deep
can you give us the number
north of six figures
yeah
so when you're in like a gambling hole
is that like you're using boogies are
you like no I'm not I'm using my money
to get out I don't want to use no bookie
or
what was your game
Blackjack oh yeah they were like I see
roulette I love roulette roulette I love
her that you know what's [ __ ] up about
roulette is you'll [ __ ] get to a
table
and you'll see like you always think
that there's a strategy to roulette but
there isn't now there's ways you could
play to increase your chances in Vegas
and to SLS I play roulette everywhere I
go yeah I like relaying craps but what I
do is I'll bet
um you know how you could bet the
outside the thirds
so I'll bet two of the thirds at the
same time yeah and if one of those hits
I win because they pay two to one you
know so if I put 10 on each one and one
of the two hits I win ten dollars in
profit if I lose I triple up that bet
onto and you keep tripling every time
you lose and then it's it's a strategy
it works but it's also if you get on a
losing streak you're like you could be
[ __ ] asked out unless you're on like
yeah I love roulette though well that's
amazing
so you've you discover gambling gambling
[ __ ]
gets to the point where you're six
figures in the hole I ain't got nobody
called but Kobe right
and Kobe Saves the Day
the cheapest man I know probably
wow
and like that's not an easy call to make
I don't know like let me call one of the
greatest players of all time I got Pride
one of my closest friends and ask him
for some money did he make you pay it
back
he was a great businessman you know that
yeah
so you had to pay it back of course
well I mean
you did pay it back of course nice and
interest no no wow
shout out to Kobe save the day man
crazy where like like for you
would you say that
his death you know because I think it
was very like
I said dude just for America it was
right before the pandemic too
um how did I mean just for you man like
how did it hit you where were you at
when you found out about the news
I was in Atlanta
I was in Atlanta
and I know the man so I was like they
told me helicopter crash I was like yeah
I just
jumped out landed on his feet yeah
I didn't think it was that bad
they're funny to my man and I was with
foreign
up
wow
he don't even know Kobe this is what I'm
thinking about myself I'm like damn he
throwing up him who know being
it's cool it's like one of those things
that I think probably because the way it
happened they don't even really seem
like real it's the way to me it's the
way it happened because it was like his
daughter was with him like we know that
he's not here right obviously you know
what I'm saying right but it just don't
really seem real
you know it's it's pretty wild
it's definitely uh
like I said man as a basketball fan and
I I I'm a Laker hater I grew up rooting
against Kobe yeah
and that [ __ ] I was like I've watched
this dude my whole [ __ ] childhood
like
I played this [ __ ] like like I
didn't know him but I felt like I knew
him you know what I'm saying
yeah it was it was a big loss man
definitely uh crazy which ring for you
Matt the most
which year
2010 because it was the Celtics
um
they [ __ ] shook our bus 2008 when
they beat us about 40 or whatever yeah
they wouldn't even leave the [ __ ]
Arena
that would have been the year that you
beat my Phoenix Sons in the Western
Conference Finals or no that was true no
I think you weren't on the team
I think that was 2012.
we the Lakers beat the sons yeah I think
I don't think you're on their team
it was uh yeah that was uh
that was you know we did beat the sun's
one year you know in the playlist
I mean with Steve Nash right
I mean
we also
beat y'all when you guys were those
three one the eights the eight seed days
what was up three one area yeah in the
first round and we came back
we'll do it Steve Nash
Tim Thomas hit the tree Tim I was there
L.A yeah I was I was out I was out yeah
yo Tim Thomas was also solid on the
clippers for a little bit but Tim Thomas
was [ __ ] beast he made some big shots
for us or no no I don't think he was on
the Clippers he we he hit a shot against
the Clippers though in the playoffs for
us
Tim Thomas in high school was Beast
he was the same size that's crazy how
tall are you 6 10 yeah
I'm the same size in high school that's
crazy
now for you
outside of yourself who's the greatest
Sixth Man of all time
Michael Cooper
okay
Ginger more Crawford
Jamal Crawford man I'll say Michael
Cooper first because
impact the game right if Jamal Crawford
is off that night then
true he was a he was a real like like
streaky guy but when he was on 50. put
50 up for everybody he played for he
played he played for the Suns a few
years ago put 50. well he's tough though
yeah and then and then do we put Lou
Williams in there anywhere
six minutes yeah this day next yeah
easily
yeah shout out to Lou yeah what about
Charlotte's a little living with two
women
yeah he's got the
the double girlfriend thing going could
you ever do that I wish I would have did
it when I was in NBA it would have been
made more sense than anything else than
lying
um
I wasn't mature enough to do it but I
could have did it
I feel like if you're a woman who dates
an NBA player
I feel like you kind of have to know
what you're signing up for
right
How about if you're a woman that dates a
man
um
you want to get real with it I I can't
get real with it you're married yeah
shout out to my wife shout out to white
people but now but in terms of like yo
if somebody's on the road
uh 41 dates a year
right one would expect
millionaires traveling the planet
would have
some wild uh situations that are almost
unavoidable as a man well
I was messing with one woman at the time
when I was playing NBA
and she said the difference between me
and you Lamar's that you entertaining
[ __ ]
like men we walk outside I mean the eyes
of China
hand on a dick like
I'm a good laid tonight yeah women
imagine if you imagine if women walked
outside like that and there's all
something that blue walk outside like
that but
now stereotypically that's true was
there was it was it like did you guys
know like certain chicks in certain
cities that like just everybody kind of
ran through
like the like because I mean I swear to
God bro
I know four or five [ __ ] in in
Phoenix Arizona Scottsdale
and they [ __ ] every NBA All-Star
imaginable uh and I'm like dude I mean
there's some women that make themselves
available like that but
you know
some of them are probably gonna get
married to one of one of the NBA players
sure you ain't gonna know they're trying
did you ever see guys beef out over
chicks most NBA players when you see an
NBA dude and ain't like they beat them
for no reason like how did I get out of
control it's probably emotionally over
all the time over a woman did you ever
beef with anybody over a chick no no who
was there somebody who you had like some
like actual like yo I [ __ ] don't like
this guy I'm giving him hard fouls no
because I was [ __ ] this girl or
something like that I don't know just
like you just didn't like them
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
foreign
competition can be that intense so who
did you like not [ __ ] with
like when you were playing not not
personally I just mean like yo
for example I'm a fan
I can't [ __ ] with Pat Beverly because
what he did to Chris Paul you know when
he [ __ ] hit him in the back a couple
years ago because I'm a son's fan oh I'm
saying like who who did you like who was
like your phone I never really happened
over like like if it was you know if it
was you know beef it was just beef
both of we respected each other like I
ain't like I don't [ __ ] no I ain't never
really have that type of
who's this where I'm looking to take
your head off even like even the dudes
from the oh let me see I'm gonna take it
I might take that back you gotta have a
Celtics guy huh
Tony Allen maybe yeah yeah but I'm okay
but okay but okay what I'm saying like I
don't [ __ ] with them it's like more of a
like on a court of course that's what I
mean I don't [ __ ] with them it ain't
like a off the court yeah cause Tony hey
Tony Allen was a [ __ ] yeah but like
Paul Pierce I ain't like Paul Pierce
yeah you know what I mean
if he was off the pick and roll if I
could trip him or something like that to
make him let him fall
I would do it and he's still Petty as
hell he shows on LeBron every time he
gets a chance or somebody was jealous
yeah yeah yeah Paul Pierce you know he
had to get Ray Allen and uh kg to you
know you know what I mean when that
happened it was that was like the 0809
season they win the first year
did you guys like
because that was I know everybody talks
about LeBron going to Miami but to me
the real first like super team of that
when they've been doing that [ __ ] what
they've been doing if I'm talking about
that era when Ray Allen and kg went to
the Celtics and won it they went from
worst team to the best team yeah that's
not what happens when your team get
better and the only one big players that
hate on it
make your team better [ __ ] get
in the gym yeah but I'm saying when when
the Celtics formed that Trio and
obviously that Rondo is a rookie but
like that was great for basketball it
was great like you guys were excited for
it yeah you're not gonna always be one
two yeah look at Larry Bird magic oh you
had Larry Bird uh Mikhail Parish you got
magic worthy Kareem right oh those ones
like oh my God they got a super team
well those are super teams for sure what
I'm saying but it was expected if you're
the GM of the Lakers how do you fix this
year or just fix the team in general
there's not a lot of assets
seems to be Robin Lincoln put together a
pretty shitty roster but you know that's
neither here nor there if you had his
job what would you do differently
it depends on
what my goal was if the goal was to win
like right now if I had to win more
games right right now yeah then you
probably have to make a drastic change
then the DraStic change they probably
have to make it probably people wouldn't
probably even
begin to Fathom what the drive to change
would be
here's how I trade in LeBron
so you would trade LeBron I'm saying I
wouldn't do it you would I wouldn't do
it but you're saying if I was a gym f
my responsibility was to make the team
better right now
how would that make it how much do we
have to because you have to get better
players and you can get two to three
players right now so why not trade A.D
oh you can trade ad
they gotta trade I would think because
from LeBron you probably would get more
for him because
who's Lebron he's going to change the
culture
to your for your organization for the
next
two or three years maybe you haven't
yeah I mean he's got a small win I feel
like A.D I think a team should probably
be scared to take A.D because he ain't
played 82 games the last two seasons
right
and you brought up training LeBron I
would never trade LeBron personal I call
him guard James
LeBron or Jordan
who's to go Michael Jordan I think
you're wrong but that's not a hero I
think I'm wrong yeah I love Jordan he's
up there how old are you hey Jordan's my
favorite you didn't get to see Michael
Jordan of course as a child I have his
posters all over my wall but I still
just think LeBron's better he's been
doing that at a high level way longer
than Jordan did
think about it
the year that Jordan came back and
played with the Wizards by the way he
still was putting up buckets almost took
him to the playoffs
I don't I just think I've used like it
I don't know about some people that
watch basketball the last 20 30 years
and really got to see Michael Jordan
I just think that the reasons why
Michael Jordan is great like LeBron just
can't live up yeah but it's cool to be
suck it though but you could say the
same thing about Jordan Jordan wasn't as
great of a passer as LeBron Jordan oh he
couldn't do some things better but just
Michael Jordan to I mean LeBron's in
what year 20. yes he's an amazing player
I agree with you I agree with you
I agree with you there's just something
about Michael Jordan is the it fact did
you play you know and you know what it's
no of course I mean yeah it's the six
rings it's the killer it's it's the
Killer Instinct the man you just can't
really compare players strictly
basketball all time
LeBron or Kobe
Kobe Bryant for the same reasons why I'm
picking Michael Jordan you putting Kobe
over LeBron yeah I mean he's your for
one game I'm talking about for one game
I mean you got one game two possessions
we're talking about the goat list here
yeah
Kobe Bryant you put Kobe over LeBron
Kobe Bryant and the reason why I'm I'm
picking Michael Jordan I mean Kobe
Bryant because
Michael Jordan
he's the
set the ball yeah
and
Kobe Bryant was the only one that was
chasing Michael Jordan's greatness
and it was obvious
yeah I don't know man from his walk from
the fade away
digital his will you um [ __ ] had
81 points man you
got when you got drafted Jordan was
already retired right but then he did he
come back to the wizard just while you
were already in the league
I got to play against Mike one year one
time and I have food food poisoning oh
[ __ ] so when I went on the court I seen
two mics
no no bueno
was this when he was on the Wizards
yeah we just in DC yeah
I mean it still had to be pretty cool to
say it was cool you guarded it was cool
to meet him though I met him the first
time I met him in Phoenix
great place
and Mike Tyson was in the club sounds
about that same night he used to live
there I was in a club with Mike Tyson
and Michael Jordan Phoenix got some
incredible white women though they got a
lot of great everything white women
Latinas it might be the hot white chick
Capital the pink toes bro yeah that's
what we call them in the league the pink
toes does that have to do with their
nipples or their toes they see if they
feet you know my friend Conway the
machine he calls white women he said he
likes Dusty feet he said I like dirty
food white [ __ ] dirty foot white
[ __ ] wait a minute so you
by the way
a scenario in which you Mike Tyson and
Michael Jordan are in the same nightclub
I know yo let me tell you something yo
so I'm in the club I'm with my man my
reach Taylor
and I'm like yo Moe
why I can't stop looking at this
[ __ ]
um
I can't stop looking at this [ __ ]
like it's like he was glowing like you
ever seen when Chappelle said about Rick
James that he had like seen his Aura
yeah coming off him like I could really
his presence was that strong you know
what's funny I went to a Simba concert
like a few months ago
and
all of a sudden behind me was LeBron
James and his wife yeah and I was the
same way yeah I was just like
damn he's with his wife or I would buy
the room yeah I'm like [ __ ] you know his
presence was like
it was like it was
become strong
did you party with Mike Tyson at all
that night no
I feel like that would be a legendary
hanging back in the day Lamar Odom
I feel like that'd be pretty easy to do
have you done this podcast you got to
make that happen yeah it's out here and
he's got his he's got the weed [ __ ]
going crazy yeah he's gonna try to talk
you into smoking a toad though the toad
that's his [ __ ] that's that DMT no it's
not his [ __ ] DMT what's that it's the um
it's it's pretty much the active
chemical that's a psychedelic yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy but that [ __ ] you
almost you actually you have to freebase
it yeah so it's it's like it looks like
you're smoking right up my alley
right up my alley psychedelic Freebase
I'm with it oh man yo Lamar tell me
about the craziest night of your life
that was not the night we all know about
where you almost lost your life give me
like peek party in Lamar is it a bunch
of women are you having a foursome are
you what what's going on I think the
craziest night oh I think Chloe she came
into this [ __ ] hotel room at
the Roosevelt okay you and Chloe no I
was at the hotel room with some other
women oh she came and she'll tell them
she started beating the [ __ ] ass
Dr Roosevelt so you're in the room with
just one or two you forgot how many
women it was more than one though for
sure
possibly it could have been more so
Chloe finds out you're there yeah I
don't know how the [ __ ] you know how I
was there though because she's a woman
how do you know which hotel
because she she probably knows people
bro she's Khloe Kardashian she probably
you know slipped the guy at the front
desk I don't know okay so you're
cheating on Chloe yeah she shows up what
happens next
I don't know she just started [ __ ] a
girl up Jesus we got the whole at The
Roosevelt Hotel I had to like get her
off the girl
I'm still I'm thinking about this girl
gonna press charges right
TMZ
but you know I got to got the guy off
the ground
did you guys end up like
the girl never went to the police
oh she was a real one oh I couldn't I
wish I could remember who it was
hmm
how many times because you know you and
Chloe had a a relationship that I think
was uh we got to watch it on TV people
love y'all you know what I'm saying
people loved y'all together
were you like I mean like you obviously
you cheated but like how many times you
get caught cheating
by Chloe
too
that's not bad she seems like a
forgiving person she is
she wiped my eyes when I was
recover yeah
hey what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our folks at hardean Las Vegas you see
them right there you know I mean shout
out to hard D Man shout out to everybody
over there it's the uh illest dispensary
in the world number one they got the
craziest selection of weed you'll ever
go to when you're in Las Vegas there's
only one place to go that's Hardy and
you pull up you say hey I heard about
this place on the bootleg cat podcast
and they're gonna get you hooked up with
some [ __ ] weed all right so go to
Jardin Las Vegas right now if you're in
the city of uh sin or you're going make
sure you uh you know put it put together
a little hour off to the side to make
sure you go get your nice [ __ ]
Harding bag full of uh just a premium
weed all right and not only that you got
to shoot them a follow Harding
underscore Las Vegas I'm gonna shout
them out though because Harding smells
the best the dispensary is just it's not
only the best dispensary in the world
it's the best smelling dispensary in the
world and look now the bootleg cat
podcast smells like Jardin because I
have the Jardine signature scent candle
you could have one too you could go to
[ __ ] Hardy in Las Vegas just saying
also make sure you follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas that is
important you have to follow them
because there's some [ __ ] accounts
out there we appreciate hard Dean when
you're in Vegas pull up go get you some
smoke go get you some edibles go get you
some [ __ ] carts whatever it is they
got it and they got it at the highest
quality it's the only place I'm smoking
from that's hard in Las Vegas let's get
back to the interview is there a
I feel like we always hear about people
who who are inside of that family and
how like it comes with a lot of pressure
because obviously it's the most famous
family in the world you know what I'm
saying is there any truth to that like
once you kind of get into that
Kardashian gang there's just things
change in terms of like obviously you
have a lot more eyes on you but do you
feel that pressure is it like palatable
where's pressure but I'm actually a
championship athlete
if anybody
for a hell of the pressure with me yeah
I didn't handle the power I'm good you
feel me yeah is this power that comes
with that [ __ ] for sure
yeah
were you uh were you around yay at all
when he was yeah he was playing the
music for me
his new new [ __ ] for me when I was
recovering
damn I [ __ ] with him for that
yeah
yeah Kanye seems I mean he seems like a
pretty misunderstood guy man he's one
he's my favorite artist ever though I
got a post whatever yeah so I got all
these albums I mean Nas is my favorite
MC yeah but in terms of artists
discography yeah it's yay yeah love yay
man
I think yeah
it's so crazy I listen to some of his
[ __ ] now I'm I realize how good it is
what what do you remember what your
hobby was playing you while you're in
the hospital
foreign
what year was it I could probably tell
you it was
2015. oh it was the life of Pablo that's
what I was just to say I think it was
the life of Pablo yeah because that came
out in 2016. yeah that's fire [ __ ] all
the new [ __ ] that [ __ ] woke my soul up
because I was really dead
at that time I think that's why I got
kind of like
lost Chloe because my mind I couldn't
really
um
express myself how I was feeling express
my thoughts
you know what I mean yeah after not
being able to talk [ __ ] took me a little
while to learn how to talk and walk
again
crazy man I can only imagine you had to
write [ __ ] down yeah and it's not like
even if you write something down you
ain't really getting out your thoughts
like how you want to get them out this
is not with the fluidity right
yeah that's crazy man well look you've
uh you've had a hell of a
Redemption story that you're still doing
man yeah I ain't stopping I got some the
ketamine Clinic you heard of Academy
I have heard about how it can be like
beneficial
I don't know the details though so maybe
you can I got these um
these clinics coming out maybe you can
make have you um try it out well what
what is it because we heard a cat like I
know ketamine like the party drug right
got the party drop right because they're
starting people get stuck in a k-hole no
done this way
she can help with
PTSD depression and addiction yeah I've
heard about that I think in today's
society I probably need it because
everybody's suffering from
one another
after we all kind of after the pandemic
just
basically put us in jail basically the
last two years right
everybody not really meant to do a bit
you ain't lying you feel me yeah so a
lot of people lost their minds so you
have
you're you you have like a ketamine
Clinic that where people can kind of
safely administer it for therapeutic
purposes
is that something that you've actually
done and it was helpful I don't get high
that's great man I don't think about you
huh as fast as I think about that word
cocaine come in my mouth
and leave
what is like uh
you know
workers work every day in my
relationship with God yeah I spoke my
marijuana that's about it weed is fun
I think I think I think we all know like
we I think weed and psychedelics should
just you know I don't know if we can
consider those drugs because they're so
beneficial well I think so for some
people marijuana
opens the Gateway that's what goes it's
true it is true so have you not really
strong and disciplined right
knowledgeable about marijuana
you know what I'm saying you need to
know everything about it before you
indulge in heavy
yeah I mean
I know people who started smoking weed
and then I mean I I mean yeah I think
it's definitely a game it's a certain
truth to it being I know people some
people don't smoke weed would never [ __ ]
with cocaine or anything else you'll
hardly ever find somebody who's never
smoked weed but they're huge cokeheads
like show me that guy yeah I've never
smoked in my life but I love [ __ ]
Coke yeah yeah
that shit's crazy
so you don't even think about cocaine
anymore
that's good man
do you do meetings
nah I just stay close to God
you know what I'm saying my little
ketamine sessions yeah
prey on it
I think I understand the um
risk and reward
um
you feel me yeah it comes down to that
yeah the cat you did they do Academy and
they also do you would also do a MDMA
like a therapy
yeah for PTSD
well there's a depth while you started
right now
we'll get that prescription no no it's a
real thing though yeah yeah they uh MDMA
there's like MDMA trials that help
veterans get through PTSD same thing
with the psilocybin the mushroom [ __ ] A
lot of that [ __ ] if administrated you
know uh properly that [ __ ] is beneficial
but I think that's what any drug
honestly he said maybe not crack I don't
know no no
yeah it's yeah uh or cocaine I don't
think I'm gonna be beneficial
cocaine yeah because even if you're
[ __ ] on coke
yourself yeah you do a little bit a
little bit too much so while you're on
coke are you simultaneously taking gas
station dick pills joking I'm joking my
dick off if I am Patrol
I only won't get into that nah man I
just wonder because like you got to do
how to do the Viagra and the coke yeah
you gotta keep your dick hard yeah so
it's it's all downhill from there yeah
that Viagra [ __ ] is serious
you wake up in the morning with the
hardest dick of your life you take a
Viagra the night before you wake up in
the morning and you're [ __ ]
that's the perfect dick though yeah
of course but yeah you ever do the gas
station rhinos
like you or the honey the honey pack the
honey pack don't do nothing
I feel like the honey pack is like
immediate because every drugs work
different for that's true that's true
yeah I just you know the Mexican Viagra
always is a safe generic Vibe and now
they that shit's like not even like a
trademarked by Pfizer anymore so there's
by the way
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg what's
that boost Bluetooth it is the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's in a chewable form you don't
have to go to the doctor It Gets Sent
right to your house and if you use that
promo code it's it's a it's for your
dick what is it Bluetooth
oh you just need one for me I'm a Double
Dipper bro
I'll be trying to be a RICO throw you're
a [ __ ] Wild Boy so you'll be [ __ ]
Turks up 200 milligrams of well listen
blue choose fire and it's you know they
sponsor the bootleg cat podcast and I've
taken them oh do they yeah shout out to
Bluetooth somebody want to sign up um do
my podcast make it happen so we got to
get back
and you'll use the product obviously on
the show oh [ __ ]
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg and
you'll get your first month for free
um I I kind of want to get back to the
basketball a little bit man uh who was
the hardest player that you had to
defend where you just knew that night
was just [ __ ] I I this is who I got to
get on
Zach Randolph oh Zebo
and he was he was [ __ ] it's a beast
and he wouldn't he won't stop and he's
like I don't think people understand
like zebo's like he's like built like a
house how good he was so it was pound
pound pound pound Pound and he gonna
finish him yeah finesse then pound pound
Pound even like back to the Blazers days
he was good and all game long till he
coming with it um
and whatever his team whatever team he
on his team is they like looking to go
to him like he probably he's like the
leader yeah yeah offensively did you
guys ever get high together like on weed
because I know he's a big pot smoker no
I think my Zebo be blowing down them
tree well [ __ ] he got hit in Sacramento
with like five pounds of weed or
something yeah my trip who else what's
up with rappers traveling with pounds of
weed or not rappers uh Royal players
want to be rappers rappers want to be
ball players it's always been that huh
yeah did you ever try to have a go at
rapping I got my 16 on my podcast you
ain't here I mean I saw the freestyle
that you put out like that was viral
like 10 years ago no oh no yeah that was
the high freestyle
yeah but this one I did I did it for my
podcast
it's below 16 on it it's cool when you
were did you like uh obviously being
from Jamaica I mean home of 50. and lost
boys too hey yo shout out RRP free
guitar yeah
um yeah Mr Cheeks man damn Love The Lost
Boys
uh what was there because you got
drafted in 99 so that's about the time
well Lost Boys was popping and I feel
like how to uh how to rob might have
been in that same time window 2000 2001.
yeah like did you and 50 ever have a
relationship being from the same place
no I mean um me and cheeks me and cheeks
do though that's dope man
shout out to to to the Lost Boy shout
out to Mr Cheeks man nice camera action
God damn it
um okay so we the hardest player to
guard was Zach Randolph what about
uh
the dirtiest player and I don't mean
dirty in like a bad way I mean like you
know there's dirty players no Zach
Randolph he was a good dirty yeah
there's every every possession
what was it like guarding Tim Duncan a
guy who I never really guarded Tim
Duncan a lot he probably played the
center of power probably going home
alone you were pretty much at the three
right before another four three or four
okay
Tim Duncan was a [ __ ] though he
was so patient took his time and also
like no emotion right like you know it
don't it like I feel like he's not the
type of Dude to react to [ __ ] talking or
talk [ __ ] back no he talks [ __ ] but just
he just he talks [ __ ] differently
and I'm like yeah [ __ ] get your
ass up get your ass up
what about like the phrases what about
the biggest the best trash talker in
your career that you would you played
against
probably be Gary Payton but when when I
came into the NBA like talking trash
like they kind of like took that out the
game a little bit
right they don't really like just yeah
[ __ ] and one damn you can't get
into like you know how Larry Bird and
used to be in each other's face talking
[ __ ] talking crazy [ __ ] can't do that
right now yeah well look you got your
podcast yeah uh plug that real quick
what is it called on the low on the low
podcast
look for that joint is it coming or is
it out it's coming there's no it's out
it's out so first episode
yeah we did it I did an episode
yesterday with dog face you know dog
fixed um the Mexican dude yeah the
skateboard yeah and the cranberry juice
you got to start Barry you got to go on
Mike Tyson's podcast I will you have to
yeah I will that'll be legendary thanks
what oh man oh well to be a fly on the
wall in the nightclub that Michael
Jordan and Mike Tyson and Lamar Odom
wearing so I would say [ __ ] time
that's [ __ ] crazy not to mention the
night where you're hanging out with
Prince while being in trouble yeah
listen Lamar Odom you're a legend man I
appreciate your time appreciate you more
bro yes sir go go uh support the podcast
you got the weed coming out uh how can
they figure out December 3rd you get
anywhere
um it's gonna be everywhere cookie well
how can they learn about
um the ketamine Clinic
or is that coming soon
um
it's coming soon how can they learn
about the ketamine Clinic Arden
that's a good question
just stay stay close to your IG right I
got you here Stay Stay um close to my
ignition appreciate your time brother
I'm popping on here yes sir Lamar Odom
fire